une caméra cachée bien sûr et vous savez
en hiver quand on le peut on tourner à
l'intérieur parce qu il fait meilleur et
que les gens restent plus facilement
avec nous alors au centre beaugrenelle
il y a deux escaliers roulants
il y en a un qui monte et il y en a un
qui descendent les frères louis comme
les frères alors si on bouche le haut
quand les gens sont engagés et si on
bouge le bas à bien les gens sont
obligés de faire un circuit quoi de
monte et descend ce sont des gens qu'on
débat des eaux des hauts et des bas mais
comme je le disais c'est ce qu'on a fait
au centre beaugrenelle avec la
complicité de la direction que nous
remercions ici voici l'est les escaliers
roulants piégée
tout d'abord un américain à paris est
pris au piège d'une autre escalier
roulant en hausse et des affaires net et
cyril tiaret intraitable
comment ça je commence à orner vous avez
l'expérience et tout en fait
pascaline à bord avant
et en bas jacques legras va bloquer à
son tour c'est l'heure
celle qui permet là
cette obéissance votre billet de
remontée saramon
je souris
et comme macarthur il a dit à jacques
legras je reviendrai est une première et
d'aller leur cave à continuer à
accompagner ainsi d'autres qui ont pour
recueillir leurs impressions
je suis là ce dernier permet là où
allons-nous vers la route c'est le cas
mais je sais pas comment faire l'amour
descendu jusqu'à présent
auparavant
aussi par dans le ciel ça fait une
petite bande malgré ben oui
voilà qui a le temps de se promener
comment notre héros
pardon au compteur soit leur choix bah
oui c'est franchement que c'est pas des
escaliers roulants
ouais
on nous amuse et en os et non plus trop
maintenant j'espère gagner ou john key
qui sort des sentiers battus
je demande pas mieux
on va essayer encore j'ai alors vraiment
ah oui ça c'est sûr
ah oui ça vous avez c'est bien français
mais les français ça souvent le sens de
l'humour c'est terminé oui vous avez
lancé miss se taisait depuis vendredi
maintenant oui
et il ya lire cliente qui m'ont kata 4
pour mieux se casser le nez en eau
à cesky sa valeur des modèles me reste à
savoir si madame ont vacillé normalement
et qui se précipitent pour retrouver
jacques legras en solo
voici maintenant il va vous laisser
passer ici c'est clair mais maintenant
avec la guerre
total s'était ouvert ici et c'était
fermé là haut et maintenant c'est le
contraire c'est de ne pas sortir du nord
alors oui c'est la richesse en talents
question nous vient d'avoir un jour on
gagne
ben ali non non non
pourquoi n'y en a pas
janot en avril vers un bassin fermé sine
mais je ne suis pas dans un bon jour de
plus pas de nom
w on va essayer de redescendre à la
jambe souvent la femme venait
venez on va demander à l'agent du réseau
global arab est ennuyé comment madame
est ennuyé elle voudrait sortir du
moment là on attend maintenant vous
allez bien c'est possible la vallée sa
piste fétiche et la voilà prête ou moins
j'espère alors oui madame
paris veut se concentrer
je vais là venez venez là vous menez
pour assez ridicule
dans cette saison 2 c'est ici que de
deux permanents madame venez je veux
dire c'est sur la glace et le podium en
scène c'est pour antennes 2g pour la
caméra cachée